Deputy Planet Mr Speaker
I have been asked to reply
Global oil prices have remained largely
stable this year this has not changed
following the announcement of additional
production cuts by Saudi Arabia and
Russia we expect the impact of the cuts
will be mitigated by the increase in
Supply from other producers and a
decrease in global oil demand as we have
seen previously
speaker of who you want to insulate
ourselves from future price Rises and we
need to invest in our Greenhouse United
the United States gets it they've
committed 370 billion on Net Zero
energies the EU they get it they're set
to match that figure and in Scotland we
get it we have the ambition to lead the
world unrenewable energy we have the
energy but we do not have the power to
wires Westminster Frankie block
Scotland's path krasifa Greener future
[Applause]
well Mr Smith
to speak in Renewables but I would say
to the party opposite we should also
invest in our energy Independence and
that means investing in the North see if
we fail to invest in the North Sea we'll
be more reliant on foreign producers and
we will have higher carbon emissions as
we import from elsewhere Craig McKinley
our question two Mr Speaker
Deputy Prime Minister
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker my right honorable friend the
prime minister is in Vilnius attending
the NATO Summit
this Summit is an opportunity to build
on the work we have done over the past
year
strengthening NATO and supporting
Ukraine Mr Speaker in addition to my
meetings in this house I shall have
further such meetings later today
McKinley Mr Speaker new Labor's old
Mantra used to be education education
education its new one seems to be tax
education tax education tax education
does the Deputy Prime Minister share my
disgust at Labor's plans to tax
education and choice which could lead to
40 000 pupils being sent into the state
sector with the cost of to the taxpayer
I have a number of English language
schools in my constituency and they are
concerned that this will apply to them
as well as well as tuition out of hours
tuition and sports uh training uh
additionally uh does the Deputy Prime
Minister object to these measures as
strongly as I do
[Applause]
yes well once again we have seen from
the labor party then putting the
politics of Envy above the interests of
children in this country and as my
honorable friends rightly highlights
recent analysis shows this could lead to
over 40
000 pupils leaving the schools they're
in placing further burdens on existing
schools and costing 300 million pounds
now come to the deputy leader of the
opposition Angela Reyna
and I know you're a keen historian so I
looked up the last time a prime minister
missed two sessions in a row with other
engagements which was March
1996 and I'm very proud to be filling
the boots of Lord John Prescott but I
think it's safe to say he's no hassle
time
why is it John Prescott asked that in
Tory Britain tens of thousands of
families are facing repossession
negative equity and homelessness and can
he tell us 27 years later why am having
to ask the same question
[Applause]
clearly the right or wrong lady did not
listen to my previous comments the prime
minister is at NATO of course that
wouldn't be a problem if she'd had her
way her old boss wanted to abandon
Ukraine abolish the Army and withdraw
from NATO and he certainly wouldn't be
going to any Summit Mr speaker
[Music]
and it and when it
and when it comes when it comes to house
building I will take no lectures from
the party opposite on home ownership my
parents would not have been able to buy
their own home if it were not for
Margaret Thatcher and the reforms
introduced by her government and this
government is building on those with
record house building
Mr Speaker I think he's taking lessons
from the former prime minister on
telling the facts the last the last
Labor government worked hard to
dramatically reduce the number of
children in temporary accommodation but
under the Tories the number of homeless
children as risen by 75 percent I'm
proud of our record on tackling child
poverty does the right honorable
gentleman feel ashamed of his yeah
minister
I'll tell you what this government has
done we've lifted 400
000 children out of child poverty we
have introduced the national living wage
something the party opposite totally
failed to do and increased increased the
national living wage by the largest
amount ever meaning 1 800 pounds for
working people and cutting their taxes
by doubling the personal allowance that
is the surest way to ensure we lift
people out of poverty and would never
have happened with the party opposite
Angela radar Mr Speaker it's like the
ghost of prime minister past is still
here
and I tell the right honorable gentleman
that he should be careful about the
stats to use because the children's
commissioner warned the other prime
minister about peddling false narrative
on child poverty around those figures
the truth is rising bills and soaring
mortgages and plummeting real wages are
pushing more and more families to the
brink those already struggling are being
hit hardest by the Tory mortgage
bombshell and Rising food costs so can
he tell us how many primary school
children have been pushed into poverty
since this government took power
Deputy Prime Minister
I would say to right on wrong lady it is
this party not the party opposite which
extended free School meals to all five
six and seven-year-olds something the
party opposite failed to do and it sits
alongside many measures we are taking to
help people with the cost of living we
are paying half of families energy bills
last winter winter funded by our 75
windfall tax freezing fuel Duty helping
families with child care and delivering
on our pledge to reduce the debt it may
come as a surprise to the right
honorable lady but balancing the books
means more than working out how many
more Millions to take from her union pay
masters
Mr Speaker once again he talks about
balancing the books his party crashed
the economy
[Applause]
anyway for working people in this
country at the moment new research out
today shows that 400 000 more primary
school-aged children are growing up in
poverty since his government came to
office
why does he think that is the prime
minister
I will take absolutely no lectures
whatsoever from the party opposite about
how we help children in the most need it
is record investment from this
government in education two billion
pounds more this year two billion pounds
next year which is giving those very
children the best possible start in life
ensuring that we have the highest
reading standards in the western world
and I have to say to thee I have to say
The Honorable lady
listen her leader says he hates Tree
Huggers they seem very keen on hugging
that magic money tree
foreign
Mr Speaker he doesn't even acknowledge
it let alone explain why child poverty
is rising what hope has he got of
solving it so let me try a simpler
question for him how many kids don't
have a permanent address today compared
to when labor left office in 2010.
Deputy Prime Minister
we could exchange all these numbers
across the dispatch box
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
these are the numbers that matter there
are 1.7 million fewer people in absolute
poverty under this government 400
000 fewer children
200 000 for your pensioners and one
million fewer people of working age
because the single best route out of
poverty is a job and record numbers of
people for million more people under
this government have got a job that is
the difference between this party and
the party opposite who always leave
office with unemployment hire
Angela Rayner Mr Speaker what matters is
what people feel every single day at the
moment who are going to work and can't
afford their mortgage can't afford their
rent and can't afford their bills
because of this conservative government
there are 55 000 more children without a
permanent address today compared to when
they took office 13 years ago we've gone
from a labor cabinet focused on tackling
child poverty to Tory ministers who
won't even admit the problem just like
time in March 1996 they can only offer
excuses and not answers Lord John
Prescott said to Lord Michael hesitine
that day how can the right honorable
gentleman be so complacent in the face
of sheer misery created by his
government's policies 27 years on why
are we asking the exact same thing
[Applause]
a little bit more if we carry on come on
Mr Speaker I know there's a reshuffle
coming up on the other side but this
audition for John the John Scott's old
job
getting a little bit hackneyed
it is this government that has lifted
000 children out of poverty the party
opposite I hear the ride my lady
claiming to be the party of working
people but under their policies people
can't even get to work they support just
stop oil protesters blocking our roads
they support their union pay masters
stopping our trains and of course they
support the hated Euless stopping cars
across our Capital while conservatives
get Britain moving labor are standing in
everyone's way
[Applause]
[Music]
given the mansion house compact does not
encourage our Pension funds to invest
specifically in British companies what
more can the government do to encourage
greater investment in our companies
especially the climate technology
startups which are increasingly going
abroad to find the funding they require
to the benefit of our competitors
Deputy Prime Minister well I think my
honorable friend raises a very important
point about both startup capital and
ensuring that we get more money to high
growth companies I would say that the
Chancellor's pension compact is a very
important step forward and will unlock
75 billion pounds of additional
investment I'm quite confident large
amounts of that will go to UK companies
and that sits alongside measures such as
the Edinburgh forms to financial
services again which will help improve
Financial Services in this country and
unlock money for those Industries SMP
Deputy leader Murray black
thank you Mr Speaker last month the
Deputy Prime Minister dismissed warnings
from these benches that mortgage rates
were nearly back to where they were
after the disastrous mini budget this
week mortgage rates have surpassed those
levels how high do they need to go until
he and his government takes it seriously
Deputy Prime Minister
Mr Speaker The Honorable lady knows
people around the world know that the
driver of higher mortgage rates is
higher inflation and higher inflation is
caused by Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and the post
[Applause]
action it's only by getting inflation
under control that we will be able to
get mortgage rates down and that
requires discipline discipline on
spending discipline on public sector pay
and discipline on energy supply all of
which is lacking from that party
and predicts that mortgage payments Will
Rise by at least 500 pounds for a
million households the Prime Minister
says that people need to hold their
nails the chancellor said just last
night that mortgage holders should just
shop around
speaking of his own party the member for
Southwest Devon said if the circus
doesn't stop by Christmas it's over
there's a deputy prime minister
understand that people can't afford to
wait until Christmas and that they need
help right now
Deputy Prime Minister Mr Speaker the
fundamental thing we have to do is to
halve inflation that is an approach that
the IMF quote strongly endorses because
higher inflation drives higher mortgage
rates but that's not all we are doing
with the mortgage Charter signed up by
90 of mortgage providers we are giving
people help to extend their terms to go
interest only and to reduce their
monthly payments now that action is
supported by Martin Lewis a real
money-saving expert unlike The Big
Spenders on those benches Stevenson
last year I visited Abbey Field House in
wentzfield and I was impressed by this
model of assisted living for older
people that gave them the independence
of a self-contained flat but the ability
to eat and socialize together I was
deeply concerned to hear that a
consultation is underway to close the
Abbey Field House in wednesfield
um and I went back to speak to older
people they unanimously want to stay
there Abby field is a charity his
majesty the King has been Patron for 40
years now it cannot meet the cost of
updating the estate to meet
environmental standards will my right
honorable friend meet with me to see
what support government can offer to
abbeyfield so that my residents don't
have to leave the homes they love
area
well Mr Speaker of course I'm very happy
to give my honorable friend that
Assurance I I would note that we have
provided seven and a half billion pounds
of additional funding for social care
and discharge and specifically on energy
and we have got an energy advice service
to support smaller businesses and we'll
be piloting new audit and Grant schemes
which may also help
in January Emily booked an appointment
with a local dentist in chard Somerset
for the 14th of June
only to be told by a neighbor at the end
of May that the surgery had closed in
April
Emily no longer has a dentist all the
remaining surgeries aren't taking on any
new patients Emily doesn't know what to
do
so can the Deputy Prime Minister tell
Emily and millions of people like her
when can they get an appointment with a
local NHS dentist
Deputy Prime Minister well the right
order gentleman may have missed but our
NHS Workforce plan is investing an extra
2.4 billion pounds into training and
retaining crucial NHS staff including
dentists and GPS and actually the number
of dentists Will Rise by 40 and I would
say to people across that constituency
that the best way they can ensure better
services for their NHS is to vote for
Faye purbrook the conservative
candidates Charles
Mr Speaker could the Deputy Prime
Minister let us know when we can expect
allocations from the leveling up fund
round three and when it comes will it be
true to the prime minister's pledge that
all parts of the country uh will benefit
including the southeast and most
particularly the very deserving town of
Andover
Deputy Prime Minister well as well as
being an excellent Minister I know how
committed my right and real friend is to
the town of Andover we will shortly be
announcing the new approach to the third
round and further details of this
approach will be will follow shortly
Pete Wishaw
you encounter and political life that's
certain to horrify a poll or sicken you
but I don't think I've ever seen
anything quite so good task as the
painting over of Mickey Mouse on a
children's neural as was done by the
home office in a Detention Center in
Kent now no minister so far has Rose the
necessary Compassion or concern to speak
out about this so can I ask the Deputy
Prime Minister to look into the deeper
recesses of his soul and just simply
condemn it
Deputy Prime Minister I'll tell the
honorable gentleman what real compassion
looks like and that means stopping the
vile people smuggling trade across the
channel all condemning women and
children to death this government is
taking action to deal with it with our
stop the boat spill and that party
shamefully 18 times last night voted
against it
hello me
[Applause]
thank you
the party of aspiration the importance
of home ownership
according to a recent estimate by
Barclays Bank it now takes an average of
eight years for the average first time
buyer to save for a deposit and in parts
of London and the southeast it can be
longer than that what is the Deputy
Prime Minister and the government doing
in order to improve the prospects for
younger people who want to own their own
homes prime minister well I know what a
passionate champion of this issue my
honorable friend is it is actually the
case that almost 850
000 households have been helped purchase
a home since 2010 and actually in 2021
the number of people getting onto the
property ladder for the first time was
at a 20-year High thanks to initiatives
such as first homes and the help to buy
scheme of course that stands in contrast
to the party opposite who oversaw the
lowest level of house building since the
1920s
[Applause]
yeah thank you Mr Speaker with the
rising ticket prices many of my
constitutions find they can get the best
value fair by going to the staff ticket
office at Lancaster station it's perhaps
why so many of them have signed my
petition to save that thing at Lancaster
station so can I ask Deputy Prime
Minister is the closure of ticket
officers just yet another cost of living
bombshell it's in my hard-working
constituents
the Prime Minister well it is important
that the railways continue to reform
after the record amount of money that we
gave them during covid I would gently
say to The Honorable lady that if she's
concerned about her constituents getting
anywhere on the railways she should
condemn the totally unjustified strikes
which close them down week after week
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker four summers ago
the unprecedented climate change driven
Heat Wave caused irreparable damage to
chelmsford's flyover and since then
people from all across Essex have been
stuck in Chelmsford traffic jams wasting
time hitting our economic growth we
badly need a new Junction at the Army
and Navy but the funding decision has
been stuck in Whitehall so love my right
honorable friend use his powerful cross
cabinet convening powers to get Treasury
and transport to agree to the money so
we can deliver a new Junction stop the
traffic jams and get Chelmsford moving
again Deputy Prime Minister well I I
know how powerfully my ride from a
friend makes the case for this scheme
and she has done so once again in the
chamber the chancellor was sitting next
to me and would also have heard the case
I I understand that the outline case
business case submitted by Essex County
Council is being considered by ministers
right now and all relevant ministers
will have heard her injunction
Scottish Ambulance Service statistics
showed an increase in hypothermic call
outs of over 30 percent across Scotland
last winter and are staggering 84
percent in the North in December whilst
fuel calls have fallen slightly food and
other costs have risen exponentially to
end the perversity of energy rich
Scotland seeing one-third of Scots in
fuel poverty and literally freezing when
will the government bring in a social
tariff to ensure that the poor and
vulnerable can get through this winter
without calling out the ambulance
service because they're freezing yeah
yeah Deputy Prime Minister well as my
writing or friend the chancellor set out
in the Autumn statement we are exploring
the best approach to consumer protection
from April 2024 as part of wider retail
Market reforms I would just reiterate to
The Honorable gentleman that this winter
we paid half of energy bills in Scotland
that was thanks to the strength of our
Union
thank you Miss ICA
can I remind the Deputy Prime Minister
and the house that yesterday was
National remembering srebrenitza day
yeah but may I particularly point out a
little-known fact
the British soldiers took out
about 2 000 civilians
in April 1993 from srebonitza those
British soldiers were B Squadron the 9th
12th Lancers not widely known but those
2 000 people from B Squadron were
actually under my command and they saved
a huge number of lives by taking them
out and they too should be remembered
for their very Gallant actions because
it was very dangerous
Deputy Prime Minister well I I pay
tribute to my right honorable and
Gallant friend and to all of those who
he commanded in the 1990s we must honor
the memory of those killed and pay
tribute to the extraordinary courage
shown by their families by survivors and
all those members of our Armed Forces
who served so gallantly in that
situation lives
in the once Affairs committee
to the treasury about the varying
compatibility factors for Wales for
Crosshill for thameslink and for hs2 his
answer began with you are drugging me
into quite complex technical details and
then he gave no complex technical
details
I'm sure that the people of Wales would
be delighted to tackle any complex
technical details were the Deputy Prime
Ministers explained to the house why we
are paying 5 billion pounds for a white
elephant in Hsu which by now comes
nowhere near our country
thanks to the strength of our United
Kingdom the the record sums are going to
Wales under the Barnet consequentials
indeed in the spring budget we increase
devolved Administration funding by 630
million pounds that included a hundred
and eighty million pounds for the Welsh
government so we're ensuring resources
are going to Wales so they can enhance
their transport infrastructure Duncan
Baker thank you Mr Speaker it wasn't so
serious it would be comical however in
horning on the Norfolk broads I have a
whole area totally cut off from having a
mobile signal wait for it until August
because of nesting seagulls taking up
residency in the new telecoms mask
goals are protected the nest can't be
moved but let's say a family holidaying
on the Norfolk broads gets into distress
this summer they will not be able to
make an emergency call which could be
life-threatening would the Deputy Prime
Minister please help me call on Natural
England to be sensible and make sure
that the public safety reasons we can
get a mobile phone Master working in a
prime holiday location
well well we we all love the the
diversity of wildlife in this country
and particularly on the North Norfolk
Coast that he represents but I think he
makes a very strong point about the
balance between that and ensuring people
have access to Modern communication
facilities and I shall certainly take it
up with natural England gold speller
day in Day Out
the endless chaos and confusion across
government departments for them clearly
Britain isn't working now if I can
paraphrase the Deputy Prime Minister
earlier we know there's a reshuffle
coming up on their side so can you tell
us is this down to obstruction and
incompetence in the civil service or is
it rather that so many of their
ministers are just not up to the job
the prime minister
[Music]
I think you can see from the record of
this government whether it's cutting NHS
waiting lists
whether it is record funding for our
schools and hospitals we have an
excellent team that will continue to
serve all homes
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker last week we all
celebrated the 75th anniversary of the
NHS you may not be aware but it's also
the 75th anniversary of Newton aircliffe
a new town in my constituency designed
by William Beveridge
could I ask the prime minister to ask
his honorable friend the prime minister
to come and visit me as his constituency
neighbor and celebrate these 75 years
and indeed the 60 years of the community
newspaper provided by the Howard family
of the Prime Minister well I'm afraid I
I can't speak to the prime minister's
diary although I will make
representations I would be delighted to
visit his constituency if he wishes me
to attend instead
thank you Mr Speaker the day I had to
phone my bank and tell them that I was
having difficulty paying my mortgage was
one that has lived with me for years
what I found was that because my income
was so low at the time ironically I was
not eligible to switch to interest only
or get any help I never went my
constituents to feel the terror and
abandonment I felt that day can he
understand that because his complete
lack of empathy and his responses to the
deputy leader of this group suggests not
I do welcome the temporary measures but
they are temporary this is a mortgage
crisis has been two years in the making
does the Prime Minister and himself
really think they're going to fix it in
12 months prime minister
well of course it's deeply deeply
disturbing upsetting and worrying for
anyone to contemplate losing their home
that is exactly why my right honorable
friend the chancellor has introduced the
mortgage Charter now signed up by 90 of
the mortgage Market which will provide
support for people in addition to that I
would say that after three months people
on news Universal Credit can also apply
for further support
Jonathan Gillis thank you Mr Speaker a
government survey has shown that 75 of
British businesses support improvements
to the UK's sick pay system and
yesterday my right on a friend of member
South Swindon launched a report
alongside wi economics and the center
for Progressive change with ideas on how
that could be done so will my honorable
friend make sure that we get a meeting
with the chancellor to see what ideas
can be put ahead of the Autumn budget we
should also have an Inca economic boost
of 4 billion pounds to the UK economy
the Prime Minister well well my
honorable friend has ever has made a
very strong case the chancellor is
sitting next to me and I'm quite sure he
would be delighted to meet with him
thank you thank you Mr Speaker the
forced isolation of people in Care Homes
and hospitals from their loved ones
since the beginning of the pandemic and
its terrible consequences as well as the
many who died alone has left a profound
trauma we've learned the hard way that
the care of a loved one is not an
optional extra it's essential part of
dignified care my care supporters bill
would guarantee this fundamental right
and while the government recognizes
there's a problem it's recently
announced consultation relates to
visiting and not a legal right to a care
supporter at all times so would the
Deputy Prime Minister speak to the Prime
Minister about bringing forward
legislation in the next King speech
Deputy Prime Minister well I think the
uh honorable gentleman is is right to
highlight the need for for care
supporters to be able to have that kind
of access and I will take away the
points that he has raised and raised
them with my ministerial colleagues
parent Bradley thank you very much Mr
Speaker you know the value of uh
interparliamentary relations and in
particular the interparliamentary union
which was founded nearly 135 years ago
in this place and we are very honored
this week to be joined by the president
of the inter parliamentary Union Mr
Duarte Pacheco would my right Uncle
friend join his campaign to get the USA
to rejoin this very important
International Organization
well as my writing or friend knows the
United Kingdom was a founding member of
the interparliamentary union and I would
very much like the United States to to
rejoin that I'm very happy to help make
that case we're a Hobart thank you Mr
Speaker not a day goes by without
serious sexual harassment allegations in
organizations up and around the country
my private members bill on workplace
protection from harassment could go a
long way to address some of these
serious issues and indeed the bill has
full government support however it is
currently stuck in the other place but a
compromise is now inside to amend the
bill so that it can pass through the
House of Lords our rules require that
any amendment made in the House of Lords
need to come back to the House of
Commons will he ensure that a small
amount of government time is made
available in this place between now and
the end of the Parliamentary session to
ensure that this important bill will
become law
Deputy Prime Minister well as the
honorable lady knows we we have
supported the bill we are working on the
bill and my right armor friends the
equalities minister is very happy to to
meet with the honorable lady to discuss
the measures further
that completes Deputy Prime Minister
question just just let the room clear
and so the end of another prime
minister's questions this time the
deputies turn of course Oliver Daven for
the conservatives and Angela Rayner for
the labor party there so let's talk
through what's been said our Deputy
political editor sankos has been
watching with me and uh labor going in
on the cost of living crisis essentially
that's right a lot of um statistics
traded over the dispatch but oh God it
was all quite hard work wasn't it I mean
this is the problem when the Prime
Minister doesn't turn up to promise his
questions it you know the the the
comments at the dispatch box aren't from
the leaders and carry less weight and
are just simply not as uh significant as
they would be Richie said currently
obviously at the NATO Summit uh in
Lithuania last week he was at uh at
Westminster Abbey service for the NHS
and we think he is back the last PM Keys
of of
um of the summer season next week so
there's one more to go before MPS go off
uh for their recess
um Oliver Dowden who's the Deputy Prime
Minister his third outing that prime
minister's questions very very solid but
he does roll out over and over and over
again sort of the famed old Tory cliches
we heard a lot about the Magic Money
Tree we heard a lot about Union
paymasters
um you know it's kind of the sorts of
phrases that make you that make you
groan uh labor Labor's Angel Arena going
in on child poverty statistics uh home
ownership it strikes because it's
unlikely to end up being an exchange
that will particularly cut through and
benefit uh I'm kind of struck that there
are big items on the news the BBC story
for instance got no mention at all there
it's difficult that MPS could have
chosen to use parliamentary privilege
they chose not to uh uh about that uh
their big issues in Parliament like the
illegal migration bill
um if there was one moment in that
entire exchange I thought was quite
interesting it was Pete wishart from the
SNP his question was about the
um about the murals that Robert Generac
ordered be painted over in a children's
Asylum reception in in folkestone now uh
this story is first revealed by the eye
we had on safer Ridge on Sunday Victoria
Atkins the minister being asked whether
she supported it and it was excruciating
to watch her try and sidestep that
yesterday I think in the comments Robert
General was saying well that was a
Reception Center for teenagers so the
kind of Mickey Mouse images weren't
really appropriate
um but uh the staff in that Center
according to the reports were quite
upset by this and today you had Oliver
dialden who was asked directly about
this by Pete Wishard and once again
chose to sidestep the issue and instead
talk more generally about the need to
stop the boats and the people smokers
and all of that kind of thing it's
interesting there is not a minister out
there that I have seen that gives a
full-thrated defense of the decision of
what happened down in Dover so uh that
was that was a sort of notable moment
for me but otherwise it felt like
everybody in all sort of just trying to
get through it and how unusual is it for
a prime minister to miss prime
minister's questions I mean Angel Rayna
was trying to make some mileage out of
that wasn't she saying the last time
that prime minister missed two in a row
was back in 1996 I think it was so um
Richardson has missed more prime
minister's questions than any other
prime minister when when when you you
look at the stats number 10 absolutely
insistent that this is for things that
you would expect Richie select to do
visits to Washington foreign trips the
NATO Summit
um people not suggesting the Prime
Minister shouldn't go to to that so
there's a there's a robust case for the
defense but you know when when the Prime
Minister isn't there it's just sort of
you know flabby and it it doesn't
fulfill the function that that half an
hour quite important half an hour uh is
meant to is is meant to fulfill so roll
on next week okay see thanks very much
indeed